bill is in Los Angeles hi bill welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave don't
sell it because when I call sure what's
up my wife and I have a lot of student
loan debt and before I tell you how much
another promise me not to yell at me
okay the total debt is around 640
thousand dollars
oh my goodness okay telling me tell your
doctors or lawyers or neurosurgeons or
something both of us are lawyers okay
okay and now in Los Angeles and how long
have you been out of Law School
about four hours and what do you guys
make right now we make 165 thousand
householding sounds good
okay I have two job opportunities that
will both somatically increase my pole
my wife's job is it stable and good and
she can work at home and we were a 5
month old baby so her job is not going
to change if anybody's gonna make a
change it's going to be me so one of the
jobs would increase our household income
would be 450,000 if I took the job it
would take me away from my family a lot
of the time and it's not in a practice
area that I'm crazy about what's
probably not somewhere where I would
want to be long term what is a lot of
time pardon what is a lot of the time
when you show you're away from your
family all the time what's that mean I'm
gonna be overseas for six months and not
see them or you work a lot of hours no I
just work a lot hours okay and I can
probably do a lot of the work at home
yeah so I learn what does your wife in
there what is what is your wife's income
she makes one hundred and fifty thousand
from home three days a week Tom okay she
needs to increase her hours okay because
she's gone deeply into debt and she has
to monetize this degree and yeah I think
I think you take the job I mean you have
two opportunities once 400 what's the
other one
the other one will fill us up to around
350 and that one is in a practice area
that I like and I could see myself
staying there for a long time
$50,000 a year $50,000 a year and these
in this equation doesn't change my
decision so I would go with the one I
like and the one you can see yourself
doing starting about the 50 or 350 so
it's about how about a hundred spread
okay well here's the thing so you would
be making 350 yes and she would be
making a household income oh so you
would go to 200 yes or you could go to
300 yes exactly
okay so 350 and 600 I can't breathe
[Music]
so your debt free in about four years
you're living on beans and rice and by
the way her incomes coming up to 200
also yes she can stay she can stay home
but she's got to take on more hours
she's got to get her income up and then
you go ahead and take your 201 that's
less and staying in your practice but
then dude you guys have to lean into
this and you have to treat this like
your hair's on fire because your hair is
on fire